Now we know that there are four
different kinds of deoxynucleotides in DNA and each
one varies in this region here. These colored
variable regions are what we call the nitrogenous
base. It's called a nitrogenous base because
it contains an element from the periodic table
called nitrogen, that's what the N represents right
here in each of these structures. The reason
there are four different types of deoxynucleotides is because there are four
different types of nitrogenous bases. The
four different chemical structures for nitrogenous bases
in DNA are adenine, thymine, guanine, and cytosine. Sometimes we note the names
of these nitrogenous bases or bases
in shorthand by using one letter abbreviations.
A for adenine. T for thymine. G for guanine. And C for cytosine. Now if we
go back up to our strand of DNA
and we replace the nitrogenous base, the chemical structure,
with the letter that represents each base, we
get a very different looking model that's much easier
for your eyes to distinguish which type of
deoxynucleotide is in each position of the DNA. So
now take this new single strand of DNA
that has a different sequence or order of deoxynucleotides.
See if you can look at this chemical structure
of the nitrogenous bases in the single strand of
DNA and write the order of the bases
in this text box here. Obviously you can use
the key here at the bottom of the screen
to see which chemical structure corresponds with which letter.
When you think you know the right answer go ahead and put the sequence
of letters here in text box altogether with no spaces in between the letters.